so I was saying thanks for the
opportunity to be here they have enjoyed
my
stations with several of you and
enjoy following up and on discussions
later today or in the future so i was
told that i might have as long until 3
30 so i am going to try to get through
two maybe even three projects but
depending on how we go i think people
should jump in with questions as you
have them i can cut some material if it
if need be so the two main projects that
i want to talk about the first one is
work that we've been doing in our group
with New York City going back to about
two thousand eight or so basically
providing climate information to help
inform decision making in various
components of New York City and most of
what I talked about there is going to be
Climate Assessment post-hurricane sandy
what was a bit of New York City's
experience during sandy and how did the
city sort of mobilize a group of
scientists for rapid response rapid
assessment scientific assessment
basically and in the process of talking
about that we can talk about some of the
advantages and potentially pitfalls of
sort of rapid rapid assessment which i
think is you know coming more and more
to to climate science whether we whether
we like it or not then the second main
project I want to talk about is and one
think about that sort of that first work
I will spend a fair amount of time
talking about some of the decisions that
we had to make in a rapid sort of
context should we use seem of five model
should we use seem at three how should
we downscale some of those types of
topics that hopefully will be of
interest to people then the second
project I want to talk about is really
sort of a group of activities that I've
been involved in looking at sea ice in
the Arctic one study that looks at when
we could go ice free if you will in the
Arctic based on what climate models the
latest climate models suggest and then
I'll talk a little bit about some of our
work looking at how mid-latitude weather
could be affected by loss of sea ice in
the Arctic I think this is a classic
sort of risk management problem even if
the odds are fairly low that we do you
know see a really rapid drop off you
further drop off from what we've seen in
Arctic sea ice even if the odds are
really lower that it does lead to real
changes in middle attitude weather but
you can still make an hour
argument from a risk management
perspective that might be worthwhile for
a mid latitude cities and other regions
to sort of think about how they might
deal with potential changes in some of
these extreme events and if nothing else
I think it encourages us to sort of
think about the potential limitations of
climate models and we do risk assessment
ways that we might sort of go beyond
what climate models global models or
downscaled models suggest for four
possible outcomes in the future okay so
jumping right in this is sort of a quick
overview I was going to do about some of
the work in our group I'm at the Center
for climate systems research at columbia
university or co-located with NASA's
Goddard Institute for Space Studies and
i would say sort of a common theme
through a lot of our work is it focuses
on impacts it could be a range of
impacts could be agriculture could be
urban we do a lot of developing country
work a lot of work with NASA but sort of
the common theme is thinking about
impacts and increasingly adaptation as I
think I'll make clear in this talk New
York City has really done a lot in the
adaptation space for several years now
so the two projects that i'm really
going to sort of focus on the first one
is based on funding primarily from
noah's risa program we have a project
there where we're looking at the Urban
Corridor from Boston to Philadelphia
including New York I'll talk about the
New York piece but it's part of a
broader broader project with a lot of
collaborators and won't have a lot of
time to get into some of this work about
NASA but I would be interested in
talking with with some of you later
about sort of our experience in taking
some those climate science information
to decision-makers thinking about
facilities and infrastructure issues at
various centers the Northeast climate
science center is a relatively new
project let out of UMass Columbia is one
of the one of six institutions in that
consortium focusing primarily on
ecosystem issues cultural resources some
of the things that are within the
purview of Department of Interior US
Geological Survey but increasingly I
would say also sort of urban agriculture
excuse me urban eco urban ecology green
infrastructure some of these areas I
think
coming to the fore as we as we think
about ecosystems in the future another
major project that I'd love to share
with folks something called the program
of research on climate change
vulnerability impacts and adaptation
that's a unit funded project that was
very interesting to work on because
really sort of goes against that
traditional model of sort of climate
science first top down through impacts
down to adaptation it really sort of
starting from the perspective of where
are the sort of key societal
vulnerabilities today what are the big
sort of research questions and some
sense sort of independent of climate
change and people sort of go to read
this document to be rode up here I think
one of the messages is that a lot of the
sort of resilience and adaptation work
can be gun begun sort of no matter where
we go in terms of climate change we
don't need certainty about just how much
warming sea level rise we're going to
get to take a lot of steps today to to
reduce vulnerability along with a
Connecticut colleague Gary yo Co leading
the National Climate Assessment
Northeast region this time around I'd
love to talk about that with folks and
there is an opportunity actually to
participate in a technical input report
that we're developing in support of the
National Climate Assessment this time
around if folks are interested we could
talk a little bit about that okay
jumping into the New York City work now
basically as I said initially new york
city's been looking at climate risk
issues for a long time going all the way
back to nineteen ninety six or so there
was a new york academy of sciences
funded study called the baked apple some
of the big assessments since that time
the metro east coast study of 2001 in
support of the first National Climate
Assessment if we go back to say two
thousand seven or so New York City
subway system was already thinking about
heavy rainfall events that can swamp and
shut down the system the Water Authority
the DEP in New York very early on was
engaged thinking about how their
reservoirs might be affected by climate
change they've seen a big increase in
turbidity basically sediment in those
watersheds is we've had more and more
heavy rain events and as importantly
sort of at the other end of the system
in the city you know a recurring problem
of combined sewer overflow of
it's untreated stormwater running off
into the into the into the water
watersheds New York's and and then
Newman's going right through to some
current work that I'll talk about this
just to make the case that there's sort
of a long foundation in New York City
about thinking about some of these
issues so a really key event was related
to Mayor Bloomberg in 2006-2007 or so
forming plan YC a sustainability
oriented initiative that initially
didn't really include a lot of
adaptation work focused on reducing
greenhouse gas emissions and sort of
quality of life green issues in the city
so pretty early on we got to talking
with with some of the mayor's people in
the office of long-term planning and
sustainability really just sort of
making the point that adaptation needed
to be part of this equation as well that
we were locked into some additional sea
level rise warmuth and really to sort of
protect the city's legacy and even to
protect some of those mitigation
initiatives you had to be think about
adaptation at the same time so the first
New York City panel on climate change
which was a scientific body that advised
the city formed around 2007-2008 on
included climate science but also a lot
of other different components private
sector agencies to really sort of look
at some of the city's vulnerabilities
and help propose some adaptation
strategies so I want to have a slide
just sort of describing how this whole
process worked because I think
institutionally there are several sort
of elements that were key to this sort
of working so well for the city
certainly the leadership at the highest
level Mayor Bloomberg sort of attending
the sort of kickoff meeting of these
groups sent the message to all the
different commissioners that this was
something that was important to the
administration and as I alluded to
earlier part of that plan YC there was a
formation of a really sort of new group
called the office of long-term planning
and sustainability with very close
access to the mayor that wasn't situated
in any pre-existing agency so you didn't
have a lot of sort of turf war kind of
issues it was really sort of an
independent entity that all the
different agencies basically had to had
to report to and then you see the sort
of two tiered structure in terms of this
this adaptation group on the one side
the group from the last slide the New
York City panel on climate change this
is the sort of expert body as i said
earlier you have the science community
climate scientists private sector
experts to risk management people
economists legal experts people from the
insurance sector providing that climate
science information but at least as
important really sort of an even bigger
source of sort of information really the
stakeholder task force of city agencies
some private sector companies CSX Amtrak
a lot of telecommunications providers
were part of that as well it was
initially very focused on infrastructure
back in that sort of first phase of our
of our assessment work not a lot of
consideration of vulnerable communities
not a lot of consideration of Public
Health ecosystems initially a very sort
of technocratic approach you might say
with these infrastructure work groups or
center around energy transportation
paula's a policy group there was in the
sort of water and waste sanitation
issues and communications each of those
groups had a sort of very unique threat
a very unique set of vulnerabilities
different timeframes that they thought
about if you talk to people in the
communication sector as a rule that you
know the privates the telecommunications
companies the story tends to be if it's
further than 10 or 15 years out not a
big concern for us because we're engaged
in such sort of intense competition
which other with other cell phone
providers the technology is changing so
fast we pry don't need to think a lot
about what's happening sort of 15 years
from now on the other hand on the
transportation side if you're talking to
Metropolitan Transit Authority you know
thinking about bridges things that there
you have 100 year time frame lots of
really valuable assets Port Authority in
charge of the airports they absolutely
care about 100 year projections they
want to know a worst-case scenario for
sea level rise so depending on the group
you're talking to a very different set
of questions one group might be more
likely to focus on sort of a worst-case
scenario in the distribution so it was
sort of it but key part of this work was
that the scientific body met frequently
with this group asked you know
what are the things you worry about
today what are the ways their system is
impacted by weather today that was sort
of the starting point what are the
assets you're most worried about what
parts of your mission seemed the most
sort of vulnerable today that was really
sort of a starting point then the
climate science sort of came in that
helped frame you know what thresholds we
looked at it was it days over 90 days
over 95 and sort of related questions
okay so one of the I guess sort of I
think sort of take away points of that
initial assessment was to really kind of
embrace the uncertainties not just on
the climate science side on the impact
side what's going to happen to human
population living in the coastal areas
big uncertainties going out 50 years
what's going to happen two technologies
how is the vulnerability of different
sectors going to change in some of these
in some of these areas are there some
adaptation strategies that today sound
totally not feasible that might make
sense in 40 or 50 years given all those
uncertainties how can you sort of build
an approach that that is flexible to the
idea that some of these things could
change so it's obviously just a
schematic the basic idea here that
there's a societal sort of level of risk
that might very sort of how comfortable
people are with risk and that you know
as time passes with climate change
higher sea levels higher temperatures
our vulnerability is going to go up I
mean you really probably argue that this
should really sort of already start
above here but anyway over time you pass
an unacceptable threshold of risk now to
some extent if you set an inflexible
adaptation policy if you build a sea
wall but give it a narrow base so you
can't change its height later you do
reduce reduce your vulnerability
somewhat but continues to sort of go up
through time so the question we were
asking is just so there a way to do this
adaptation piece where you sort of
building more flexibility if you get new
information sea levels are rising higher
than we thought new adaptation
strategies might be possible can you
course-correct can you build you know
the stereotypical example would be to
have a broad base to your sea wall there
so you could change the height of new
information came in you're still
eventually going to get above that risk
threshold it's still going to be
untenable to live in a lot of coastal
areas if you go far enough out in time
based on our current understand
you can sort of delay that day to some
extent and of course if you add
mitigation and reduce your greenhouse
gas emissions and and get traction a
societal level you can pull that risk
down even further okay so let's get down
to some sort of more more practical
examples here now what had New York City
sort of done before Hurricane sandy
partly as a result of this this
assessment work but obviously for a lot
of other reasons too there definitely
was a program well under way to increase
green infrastructure so you think in New
York City today all the examples you see
of small parks a lot of those green
spaces that you see actually have some
you know somewhat complicated
engineering underneath them to catch and
store water as well efforts to prevent
so much stormwater runoff where it were
underway cities also was taking steps to
get more detailed information about
about some of the heights of various
various parts of the topography sea
level rise was being built into the
waterfront plan that the city was
developing and the office of long-term
Emergency Management had begun to sort
of take some that information into their
into their sort of pre storm
preparations for example so then
hurricane sandy a'course came along and
these are going to be things everybody's
probably very familiar with but some of
the things that were so unique about
sandy the fact that for parts of New
York City it hit right at about high
tide and there was a higher tide the
normal of course what's interesting to
note is that this wasn't high tide for
the whole city I mean one of the things
that that sort of emerged a few months
later was the idea that in some ways it
could have been worse it's in some ways
if the storm had hit several hours later
as it was it was sort of the worst case
for the battery and where some of the
key what we think of the sort of the
economic assets were also parts of the
south shore of the city but for some
other areas like some of the food
distribution centers in the Bronx so a
really sort of critical food
distribution center the storm actually
did not hit at high tide so it could
have you know it could have been a worst
case if it'd gone a little differently
for some other parts of the city
certainly the size of the storm was
remarkable and obviously a critical part
of determining why that surge was so it
was so big so much more than we think of
for that
wind or that level of central pressure
and also the fact that the search was
over such a big area and then you know
one piece we can talk a little bit about
was that unusual storm track as well
there's a paper by Hall and so Bell
suggesting that an angle like that storm
took along the Jersey Shore might happen
roughly once every seven hundred years
obviously big error bars on that on that
estimate but an unusual track to some
extent so in terms of the city's
immediate preparations there was a
mandatory evacuation of many areas not
all the areas that should have been
evacuated as it turned out but many
areas the subway system was of course
closed down and there were a lot of
out-of-state crews brought in before the
storm these are some of the things that
helped get things up and running faster
but clearly a lot went wrong at least 43
people died within the city itself those
estimates vary for 28 million people you
sometimes hear are left without power in
the region and seven subway lines many
tunnels shut down for a week or so some
of these impacts as I alluded to earlier
had been forecast in advance to some
extent if you go back to that 2001 study
it had graphics in it's showing the
elevation of the airports showing the
elevations of some of these water
tunnels and showing what a little bit of
sea level rise what a little sea level
rise plus storm surge would mean for
those for those for those assets and
then enough people can make out some of
these these images here damage at the
South Ferry subway station that subway
station alone suffered roughly half a
billion dollars in damage from Sandy I
was like a flag state flagship station
they had just rebuilt it new signals and
such and then sort of at the other
extreme that's the sort of high-tech
example then you have this sort of coast
along rock ways or you see this entire
set of set of boardwalk torn away and
then the extensive power outages I
mentioned earlier so what were some of
the unforeseen or maybe less predicted
or less Sun understood impacts certainly
one of the things that got a lot of
attention during and after the storm
vulnerability of the hospitals a lot of
the services right along Manhattan for
example right along the water a lot of
the hospitals flooded was there an
ability to get get people out safely
certainly there were some issues there I
think certainly this question of the gas
shortages complicated problem I mean to
some extent it was an issue of flooding
at some of the distribution centers west
of the city southwest of the city partly
just a simple issue of the electricity
being out it was it was made it
impossible to pump gas and some of these
Asians that's a problem that obviously
persisted for four weeks and then fires
to what extent were some of those fires
that we saw that of course were so hard
to manage given the fact that there was
storm surge and wind at the same time
but where some of those fires actually
caused by combination of saltwater you
know running into batteries and things
like that so those are things some of
the impact assessment things that that
we're thinking about now so what are
some of the links to climate science and
climate change of you know turrican
sandy really there's only one we've
cleared and sort of undeniable length
and that's of course the issue of sea
level rise our region has had roughly a
foot of sea level rise since 1978 inches
of that consistent with global sea level
change over that time the other three
four inches glacial isostatic adjustment
not particularly not related in any way
really to the increases in greenhouse
gases since the Industrial Revolution
but the point is really that what sounds
like not much sea level rise just eight
inches or so already is enough to shift
the probability of coastal flooding in a
significant way that's one of the real
take-home messages I'll show that when
we get to the projections even more so
more frequent coastal flooding and then
of course that eight inches made a
difference in some places was additional
homes flooded and deeper water as well
wherever it occurred so obviously the
too much trickier links to make the link
to storm strength itself was sandy made
any stronger by climate change we
certainly don't have enough evidence to
suggest that at this time and what we
can say that you know the upper ocean
temperatures have gone up by something
like a degree Fahrenheit certainly some
of Sandy's track took it through waters
that were a lot warmer than that Prime
really anomaly is much greater than that
largely just due to natural variability
but before we try to link sandy or or
cyclones to to climate change we've got
to think about all the other factors as
well what's happening the wind shear
what's happening to dust what's
happening to the stability of the
atmosphere so that's obviously you know
very very tricky one and then I think at
least as tricky is you know some of the
the research that will tie into what I
talk about in the second half of the
talk you know there has been this this
this body of research that we've that
we've been involved in pointing to the
idea of loss of sea ice in the Arctic
being consistent with a weaker Jetstream
a wavier jet stream all things being
equal that can make it easier for storms
to make a track towards the west how do
you link that to Sandy we're talking
about one storm you really can't link it
to Sandy but I think from a risk
management perspective it's worth
investigating in models and as we pick
up more observations whether we do see
more of this type of sort of wavy jet
set up with loss of sea ice in the
Arctic and potentially more of a variety
of types of extreme events but for now
purely speculative I think in the case
of Sandy to try to link it to anything
to do with sea ice although there have
been a couple papers one in oceanography
that did did explore that possibility
okay so now let's let's turn to New York
City's effort to sort of engage with New
York City Panel on Climate Change
post-sandy actually a little before the
storm hit the New York City panel on
climate change was codified into local
law is part of a charter for New York
City that even if the administration
changes when the administration changes
the city should every four or five years
sort of revisit roughly consistent with
the new IPCC reports the climate science
everything from the projections to sort
of improve physical understanding
growing observational record for example
you know some of it some of the
justifications for that now after sandy
the city reconvened the New York City
Panel on Climate Change January 2013 to
support the special initiative on
rebuilding and resilience and we
basically had about three months to do a
whole new set of projections one of the
first things we said when we engage with
the city was you know the way the
science works is the projections are
really going to change much it's
basically probably going to be very
similar to what we released three or
four years ago but the really sort of
clear message from the city was that's
fine we need a we need to find out even
if that ends up being the answer that's
okay and a related point I think just
sort of the optics being you know the
city want to be able to say that they
had gone to the seam of five models they
had sort of re free consulted the
science and so you end up in this sort
of interest in case where I mean there's
sometimes a feeling and as a climate
scientists are working with decision
makers you know you're sort of working
on very important questions with a lot
of applied value but sometimes it
doesn't feel like it's sort of advances
the science or the publications I think
this was a very interesting case where
the city really sort of pushing us to do
this work with the seam of five models
actually pushed us to do work we would
have done anyway on a faster time scale
and really sort of helped us from a
research perspective so it's sort of an
interesting case of a stakeholder
decision maker actually moving the
climate science forward the sort of this
assessment using the latest models so to
quickly sort of overview some of the
findings of our report released in June
very similar as i said to the suggestion
from 2009 acceleration of some of the
changes that we had observed over the
20th century focused on New York City
but obviously a lot of the projections
extend out to a much bigger area as well
and we'll go through some of these
findings in the next next few slides so
a quick sort of overview of trends for
the region New Haven's your values would
be pretty similar for a lot of these
variables New York City's actually had
over four degrees of warming between
1900 and 2011 far exceeding the broader
regional trends which are somewhere
around sort of two to three degrees
Fahrenheit since 1900 roughly depending
on where you are there has been an
uptick an upper trend and precipitation
in general if you compare that increase
to natural variability the trend is
pretty small certainly not anywhere
you'd want to start in terms of
projections for the future the
variabilities or continues to be the
story not the trend on precipitation
especially when you go to such a fine
scale as a city scale these are annual
precipitation and some people sort of
noted that
looks like the variability increases a
lot in the second half of that record
but I wouldn't put too much credence on
that either in terms of link it to any
climate change signal of course the
exception is the sea level rise story
there as I said earlier you know as with
all these variables you have that
year-to-year variability but clearly you
know from a risk management perspective
for a long time we've been in a state
where the trend is emerged relative to
the the earlier signal while there's
year-to-year variability from a risk
management perspective clearly we've
already picked up actionable information
that can help inform decision-making
relative to you basically another way to
say that is just the years with the low
sea level today are still a lot higher
than the years with the high sea level
work in the past so huge uncertainties
but from a risk management perspective
at what point is there a signal
beginning to emerge that can be used in
risk management for extreme events you
know we almost we don't really even try
to do trends or to attach significance
to trends at the city scale it's a risky
thing to do over the broader Northeast
we've seen about a 75 percent increase
in the heaviest rain events the sort of
one percent rainfall events that's over
a big area that's over roughly a sixth
of the country and you know we were just
talking about this during launch there
has been a tendency for a little more
strong hurricanes over the last two
three decades science is really still
out over how that whether that's going
to continue in the future or not as I
said earlier okay so there's sort of
risk management approach that I keep
alluding to what do we mean by that we
used as broad a set of climate models as
were available to sample that range of
possible outcomes 33 available GCMs
multiple representative concentration
pathways these assumptions about future
greenhouse gas concentrations to really
sort of bound a set of possible outcomes
not the full range of outcomes because
we know there are possibilities beyond
what the climate models suggest but the
city was interested in getting some
sense of sort of what these bounds were
that were suggested by the models and
you can't call it a probability being
call it a model-based distribution
so in terms of the methods and how we
went about this assessment we focused on
the mean annual changes what's going to
happen to average sea level average
temperature average rainfall but also
some of these extreme event thresholds
that the city and stakeholders
consistently asked about days over 90
degrees and important from the energy
sector perspective from the public
health perspective days below freezing a
big issue for transportation sector
obviously heating as well and then as i
said earlier use 35 global climate
models two of the representative
concentration pathways this roughly
corresponds to a one fi from the last
sort of iteration this roughly
corresponds to the s.res be one we do
30-year time slices we're not trying at
all to capture any of the year-to-year
variability we're not trying to capture
five-year variability we're sort of
focusing on whatever piece of the signal
there is that's linked to greenhouse gas
concentrations that's all we really sort
of trying to get here so 2020s time
slice is defined as twenty ten to twenty
thirty nine think of it like a climate
normal with increase in greenhouse gases
our approach was just used one ensemble
member / GCM this time around a lot of
the GCMs several of them have had many
different ensemble members we've done
prior work that suggests as long as
you're doing sort of 30 year averaging
it tends not to make much difference
whether you want to use one ensemble
member or many and we take a very simple
approach to the downscaling a lot of
people wouldn't even call it downscaling
we start at the GCM resolution and just
use the single grid box that corresponds
to New York City and then just take an
approach to calculate the extreme events
known as the Delta method where
basically all you're doing is for a
given calendar month like January go to
any one of these climate models and for
this 30-year period that I called the
2050s for example 2042 2069 figure out
the average temperature over that
30-year period for all the January's
compare it to the 30-year baseline
temperature for that same GCM over a
hindcast period roughly 1972 2000 and
just apply that change factor for
January to the historical daily data
for New York City t-max team in at the
daily scale this type of approach does
not capture potential changes and
interannual they enter interannual
variability it doesn't capture changes
in the variance within a month so it's a
limited approach but of course if you go
to those issues related to variability
the first question you come up with is
how much confidence we have about that
this approach is based on the assumption
that changes in the mean are more
reliable than changes in the extremes or
change in the distribution it's a
debatable assumption there's research on
that but that's the approach used here
yeah so we actually would take a lot of
times ends up being a grid box that's a
little to the northwest of the city but
if we look if we compare the change
factors over any of the land-based grid
boxes for these 30 year averages they're
going to be about the same in this
region if you're in a really amount in
this area it's different if use a water
based grid box the changes especially
for temperature can be a little bit
smaller so we intentionally grab sort of
the dearest one that's like fully over
land in other approach is just to
regrade everything and that's that's not
what we did here so you know we can talk
a little maybe in discussions later
about alternate approaches here what
would happen if you used regional
climate models the NARC app simulations
those are 50 kilometer resolution of
course there you know the issue run up
against with regional climate models is
basically computational expense how do
you get a combination of true
improvement in spatial resolution with a
long time scale the NARC cap simulations
at 50 kilometers are only available for
the 2050s time period you can't do other
time slices they're only available for
one emission scenario so you can't
sample that potential range of future
greenhouse gas concentrations and I
think sort of the biggest issue in terms
of what they're sampling is they tend to
be run with only a couple of these GCM
so you're really in trying to get a
little bit better finescale resolution
you're sacrificing a lot in terms of
your large-scale boundary conditions so
those are some of the issues related to
RCM certainly certainly there are others
there's statistical downscaling approach
that could be used as well we've sort of
taken the approach here with new york
city of i mentioned all the agencies
before they want to sort of unified kind
of quick approach that the whole city
can use but if you're sitting in dep and
you're thinking about the reservoirs
you're thinking about snow cover in the
Catskills that's the type of application
where you might want to look at a
statistical downscaling approach that
links historical relationships between
snow cover in the mountains with
large-scale features that climate model
might do well regional climate models
have been used in higher elevation parts
of the Pacific Northwest for example but
I think you know it this court at all
2011 paper we showed that for the type
of questions that New York City was
asking regional climate models and
statistical downscaling didn't give a
lot of value didn't lead to very
different results at all ok so just sort
of a quick take on these projections now
so when we have 35 different GCMs to
representative concentration pathways
you get a sample of basically 70
possible outcomes the city asked us for
these points in the distribution
basically so the 10th percentile means
roughly seven of the 70 models had less
than one and a half degree fahrenheit of
warming by the 2020s relative to this
1972 2010 base period central rains or
half the values falls between 2 and 2.8
you do the same thing for precipitation
in general over the Northeast and
actually even more so over the southeast
the seam of five models seem to be
suggesting a little more precipitation
than the seam of three models did in the
future it's not a strong signal but in
general there's a few more models
especially over the southeast showing
increasing preset including in summer
relative to what we saw with see map
three but still at the end of the day
the year-to-year variability with
precipitation is going to be a lot
bigger and then the kind of numbers that
we're seeing here
okay so what happens when we look at
extremes and again this is just that
Delta method based approach we're not
looking at how the distribution of
extremes could change we're not looking
dynamically at why there's going to be
more sort of blocking high pressure
systems at a sub monthly scale this is
just the sort of shift shift in the
averages I was had to go to yet ok so
just picking a couple of these threshold
extremes days over 90 over the 1970 to
2000 base period New York City average
about 18 to 18 days nine-year above so
just a small shift in the average by the
2020s this is that 10th percentile that
one and a half degrees or so of warming
if you apply that universally to all the
historical daily t-max data you go up to
24 so you can see even just out to the
2020s you're already getting under the
worst case scenario roughly doubling of
that frequency of days over 90 of course
it's also the duration of the heat waves
that would be expected to increase the
magnitude of the heat waves and even
just out to the 2050s sort of mid-range
scenario giving you something like two
and a half times as many days days over
90 so it's really hard to imagine a
situation where even that small shift in
the average could not lead to a
significant increase in the number of
days overnight you needed total
redistribution of circulation to to not
see a big increase in these in these
days overnight and this is something new
york city New Haven I'm sure as well
extremely vulnerable to today a lot of
these really warm days or days where our
quality tends to be poor we have a
greater probability the power going out
just a couple extra degrees makes a lot
of difference at the high end it's not
all a negative story of course the you
know frequency of days below freezing
you know by definition by this method
has to go down you see something like
thirty three percent you know thirty
percent drop or so in days below
freezing by the by the 2050s with this
approach okay let me say a little bit
about the approach we took to the sea
level rise projections now this is sort
of the classic case where you start of
limited in how much you really can rely
on climate models what we tried to do
here is use the latest seem up five
models for those components of sea level
rise that you
go to the models for but also to bring
in as many other components as possible
as one of the first efforts to look at
six different sea level rise components
for a very sort of hyper local city
level projection and again using the
latest climate models where where
possible so here you had about 24 GCMs
that were available for these two terms
one of them being basically the thermal
expansion the global average increase in
ocean height as it warms and the second
component the relative ocean height the
idea here the ocean height isn't
constant there's a tendency right now
for the waters along the northeast coast
to be significantly lower than the
global ocean an average some of the
climate models suggest as we get out
into the future if we get a freshening
of the North Atlantic may be partly due
to more ice melt as well increase in
that freshening may be a weakening of
the Gulf Stream which all things being
equal to tend to pull up the waters
along the northeast coast that's part of
why some of the literature yen at all
salinger at all has suggested that we
could see greater sea level rise in the
Northeast and in other areas additional
component is the fact that we have some
you know Lance of science of something
like three inches per century over most
of the Northeast okay but what are some
of these other terms that are more
challenging you know certainly the you
know the elephant in the room is always
this meltwater term what's going to
happen to the land-based ice sheets
Greenland two components of Antarctica
and to a lesser extent the mountains and
glaciers so we can maybe go into that a
little later if we have time what we did
there but we basically primarily just
went to an expert elicitation by bambor
and aspen all that really sort of tried
to bring together a bunch of different
components we know you can't use GCMs to
get these terms so we went to this
expert elicitation land some sightings
term very straight forward just do as I
say three to four inches for the region
for the first time we looked at the land
water storage this brings in a whole
different set of assumptions what's
going to happen to dam building in the
future what's going to happen to
extraction of groundwater there's a lot
of different ways you could go on this
but the bottom line is it doesn't affect
the results much at all you're talking
about sort of one to two inches of sea
level rise difference depending on which
scenario you go with and then for the
first time so these were sort of
components that we didn't look at the
last time around this time
we also looked at what's called the
fingerprint term the dominant effect is
basically the idea that depending on
where you lose that ice you see
different effects at various points in
the ocean and sort of the iconic example
of this is if you've got sort of one
let's say one metre equivalent of sea
level rise by melting ice sheets if all
that melts happen in Greenland and none
of it were to happen in Antarctica our
region New York New Haven would only get
about half the global average sea level
so we get like a foot and a half if the
global average increase was a meter and
that's some prime aerial almost
exclusively a function of the fact that
if you're losing that mass from
Greenland there's less of a
gravitational pull the water essentially
sort of moves moves away all right so
our projections based on all six of
those components out to the 2050s or so
give us under that worst-case scenario
which interestingly is the one that New
York City has been really designing to
and focusing on somewhere around two and
a half feet of sea level rise by the
2050s we're in the process of extending
this now out to the 20 80's and 2100 it
looks like as with the last time we did
these projections we're going to be
somewhere in the sort of five foot
ballpark probably by by 2100 or so and I
think based on the precautionary
principle and these long-term
infrastructure assets as I said earlier
city has been focusing on these sort of
upper end of these estimates so what
does that shift in the average sea level
imply for the frequency of coastal
flooding independent of what might
happen to storms we don't know how
hurricane frequency is going to change
we don't know how Nor'easters are going
to change in the future what is that
increase in sort of baseline sea-level
alone imply for the frequency of coastal
flooding that on the next slide here
okay so under that scenario for the
2050s what's defined is the one in 100
year flood today the flood that happens
one percent probability in any given
year just by virtue of that two and a
half feet of sea level rise by the 2050s
become saying that happens five times as
often without invoking any stronger
storms very large increase in the
frequency of coastal flooding and of
course simultaneous with that the actual
height of the floods goes up as well so
more frequent
and more damaging what they happen
without invoking any change in storms
themselves if we depict this visually
these are the updated flood maps for the
city the baseline flood risk shown in
purple as we get out to the 2020s under
an 11 and sea level rise scenario the
additional areas in yellow flooding and
by the 2050s the red flooding at 31
inches so you see there's a big
difference throughout the city some
areas the sea level rise doesn't have a
big impact on the amount of additional
flooded areas but areas where you have a
flatter coastline essentially big
increases in the amount of flooded area
and for what it's worth the one in a
hundred year flood zone you know that
obviously deserves a lot less credence
even than the one in 100 it's important
to understand as we look at these these
are not well known quantities the one in
a hundred year coastal flood this is
much sort of a regulatory tool I would
say as a sort of sort of well-known
thing given given
yeah so I think that issues of
transparency and FEMA's process have
sort of really moved to the fore to such
an extent i mean that's that's I'd say
the question that everybody is asking
and I think more information has gotten
out about the process I don't know a lot
about it but but but you know
historically it hasn't always been clear
the ways that FEMA has done that but
this is actually showing FEMA's initial
updated estimates so there's really two
things going on here actually the last
set of FEMA estimates of the 100-year
coastal flooding so we're not time at
the sea level rise yet just this sort of
baseline piece here the last time that
was done was in the early 1980s and when
that was basically being redone right
now and these are sort of preliminary
estimates that factor alone separate
from anything to do with sea level rise
is going to lead to roughly a doubling
of the number of properties and people
in New York City that are estimated to
be one of the hundred year flood zone
when we go to the 2050s 31 and sea level
rise scenario you basically double it
again so if you were sitting you know
five years or so ago with the 100-year
coastal flood maps that existed then if
you weren't considering sea level rise
you'd say they're about 200,000 people
in New York City in the 100-year coastal
flood zone today based on the sort of
current Esther now these could change
their preliminary they'll change over
the next couple of years but with sea
level rise and with those new estimates
of the 100-year flood risk the numbers
going up to 800,000 so I mean it's
interesting the city is definitely
considering that worst-case scenario and
we can talk a little bit about what some
of the reasons for that are because I
think it's an interesting question but
certainly not something we expect to see
everywhere the sort of embracing of
worst-case scenarios for shouldn't call
it a worst-case scenario but a you know
sort of more extreme outcomes all right
so summarizing the sort of New York City
piece of this now so our report was just
a sort of 50 page climate piece but
there was a much larger something like
400 450 page assessment done by the city
itself that our work just fed into that
really did look at some of these issues
how many buildings are vulnerable
focused on some of the most vulnerable
communities and i have a link you know
one of the first couple slides is
actually a link to this report on my
second slide which hopefully everyone
can get later and then some of the
recommendations basically a lot of focus
obviously on the coastal flood and sandy
risk but the city i think acknowledged
that heat waves remain one of the
biggest vulnerabilities for urban
populations especially heavy rain events
have inundated the system in the past
and will again in the future so as these
adaptation strategies are developed is
the estimated 20 billion in damage from
Sandy there's a twenty billion dollar
resilience plan it's very focused it's
focused on a range of strategies green
infrastructure elevating buildings even
some sort of flood barriers for sort of
local communities one thing that it's
not prominent in it is discussion of
retreat from the coast so I think that's
something that I you know I'd love to
talk about later it's not a message that
really emerges from this report and I
think that's important to think about
even if you sort of accept the premise
that maybe New York City is going to be
able to sort of build its way or spend
its way out of some of these risks which
is a big assumption we need to ask
whether there's a danger of other
regions that might look to New York for
guidance getting us getting sort of too
sanguine a view of the possible alka so
we knows a lot of places where there's
never going to be enough money to
prepare for rising sea levels of what we
might experience we know that a lot of
places where you can't build a seawall
right the limestone examples that you
hear about off the coast of Florida
where the water would just sort of
percolate up from underneath so retreat
you know clearly needs to be part of
part of this discussion all right I'm
definitely gonna be able to show any of
the slides on regional climate modeling
I'm going to jump now to talk a little
bit about some of the Arctic sea ice
research and this be a good break shall
we take a little break for questions or
should I keep going in and do questions
at the end the next part is a very
different topic so maybe this is a good
break point
alright was easy yeah yeah good
yep yep right right so I mean I think my
understanding is that Connecticut in
2009 or 2010 basically used our
projections for that sort of first work
that I think without of the governor's
office i'm remembering right i may have
that wrong but basically for the mean
changes average temperature sea level
for most of this region you know there
might be a few places where you have
rapid groundwater extraction or sediment
but for the most part in this area
there's not going to be big gradients in
these sort of mean changes sea level
temperature precept from one of these
grid boxes to the other now of course
when we go to something like days over
90 degrees it could be a very different
story depending on whether you're right
along the coast or not heavy rain events
can differ a lot you know as we get sort
of there's actually a pretty significant
damping of the heavy rain events as you
get so close to the water so days over
90 would be very different but the
percentage change in the days over 90
wouldn't necessarily be
yeah so that's just the kind of thing
that I'd say the city is really getting
into now looking at some of that they
have a big initiative now to map for
example as we see sea level rise our all
areas going to see sort of wave
inundation at exactly that sort of sea
level increase in height or will there
be some nonlinearities that cause some
areas to get more what's the path the
water takes when there may already be
structures sea walls in place right now
that that aren't being detected so we're
definitely not there yet I'd say a lot
of the green infrastructure initiatives
are sort of trying to do it there's
certainly efforts to do sort of block by
block modeling but I couldn't speak to
sort of how successful those are yet but
they exist I mean they're definitely
models being developed to sort of track
how water even move sort of under the
city from an urban heat island
perspective you know we're not really
sort of speaking to that at all here
except insofar as we're bias correcting
to Central Park's weather station but
that's a big researcher actually have a
project looking at that I mean the real
way to do these projections would be to
take this global climate change piece
but then also to think about the fact
that some parts of New York City you
know various times couldn't be 6 degrees
Fahrenheit warmer than others sort of
put those put those two together mm-hmm
that's yeah I mean that's yeah and that
that's a really good point retreat is
kind of too simplistic it take what does
that mean exactly could something else
be there something that can flood
occasionally I think that those
discussions are sort of being had now I
don't think it's sort of clear what the
answers are yet and there have been just
even the last few days I actually have
heard about a few buyouts in Staten
Island so that you know there's maybe a
little bit going on on the retreat
sphere but it's not what you're sort of
hearing about every day and the
initiative i would say but that's yeah i
mean i think the way i would I think I
would sort of take your comment is this
can be more nuanced this is part of a
sort of broader planning decisions about
it doesn't have to be sort of leave or
stay necessarily yep
I should show those slides quickly I
have a few things I have a few things on
that too we actually looked at the NARC
app models maybe I'm just going to
quickly show a result there then I'm
going to get into time trouble but yeah
I think especially on the extreme heat
side you know there I mentioned a little
bit of the work suggesting more blocking
events potentially but also soil
moisture feedbacks potentially can give
you a bigger increase in extreme heat
just extremely quickly if you look at
the NARC app our CMS and this is a this
is non Samba about five north cap our
seams obviously driven by five GCMs what
I'm showing here is so everything when
are kept is the 2050s relative to a base
period where you see red is places where
the warmest this is the min the coldest
day per year is projected to warm more
than the typical winter day so you see a
pretty broad area where based on these
five sort of gnar kept our CMS in winter
you'd see as much as this is Celsius is
potentially as much as six degrees more
warming in the coldest day than in the
sort of typical team in so we haven't
gotten very far at this yeah i mean the
next step obviously is is there a
plausible mechanism for this and do
these models reproduce the right type of
features when you have these really cold
days so that's sort of where we are now
but here are some of the possible
mechanisms that could influence changes
in the extreme cold or the extreme heat
and just sort of quickly to look at the
corresponding figure on the heat side so
here where you're seeing yellows and
especially Reds places where the hottest
day per year and then our cap our seams
at this 50 kilometer native resolution
are projected to warm more than the
typical summer tmax averaged across the
90 days so I mean if there's anything to
this result you know it's a knockout for
the Northeast because we're saying
earlier a couple couple extra degrees
matter but the question is you know I at
this point we're not really sort of
confident at all that this is this is a
real feature but you're right certainly
there's been a lot of good really good
research out of
Europe especially on those on the heat
side yes yeah I a lot of California
cities are there's a statewide efforts
that if I think further along the New
York's efforts we've done assessments at
new york state level we've been bigger
initiatives for example in california la
is done this san Francisco has done this
Chicago how would be some of the
examples but yeah they absolutely are at
the federal level yeah I mean you
certainly certainly I think that yeah I
mean so yeah there's a lot of ways to
handle that one I mean certainly for the
National Climate Assessment there's a
lot of effort to sort of elevate some of
these stories coming out of the cities I
think sort of widely acknowledged that
the cities are leading you know in all
this type of work mitigation and
adaptation yeah so I mean and I think
we're going to hear about some new
initiatives in the next couple months to
this Bloomberg paulson's dire initiative
is going to be you know the kind of
thing that's really going to want to
push the envelope one sort of upscaling
some of these individual city results to
to where they sort of can't be ignored
at the federal level all right i am
going to sort of do a quick spin through
some of the sea ice research now okay
all right so i'm just going to quickly
talk a little bit about trying to sort
of pinpoint how much of the recent loss
and late summer sea ice may be due to
human activity as opposed to natural
variability a little bit of projections
based on the latest climate models of
when we could go ice free and then what
might some of the implications be from
mid latitude whether i'm not going to
have enough time to get through
everything so the motivation is clearly
arcus undergoing rapid change not just
sea ice many other examples poorly
understood area lots of potential for
powerful feedbacks mostly positive but
some negative feedbacks unique and
fragile ecosystems and i was the
increasing geopolitical
importance I things been over a hundred
percent increase in ship traffic through
the Bering region just over the last
five years I think I'll skip some of the
sort of background information assume
everybody knows we've seen a big
decrease in September sea ice extent
important to note though that 2013 you
know showed an uptick that's the extreme
minimum the minimum of record from last
September's and 12 relative to the
search typical climate ology 4 sep
tember over the last 30 years sep tember
being the month when you tend to have
the least sea ice volume is also
decreased dramatically there's where we
sit in 2013 big error bars on this but
it's looking like volume has gone up a
little bit from the same point in the
last few years sea ice thickness 2013
and then some recent research suggesting
that the sea ice extent that we've
observed the last few years the lowest
for late summer in at least 14 hundred
fifty years okay so getting to this
estimation of the sort of role of human
activities this is a plot on a paper
that we're developing showing what
happens if we go look at the existing
scheme of five models when they're run
in a pre-industrial simulation of
constant greenhouse gas concentrations
and what you're seeing here is a
fraction the ratio between the trend for
all possible 33-year windows in those
climate models that don't have any
increase in greenhouse gases compared to
the ratio of the actual trend we've
observed in September sea ice extent
over the last 33 years of observations
so basically obviously a histogram
there's very few 33 year periods where
even 30 where the where the trend is
even thirty percent of the size of the
actual observed trend over the last 33
years so very few examples where even a
third where the trend is even a third is
big in the models over a 33 year period
so that makes it less likely that
natural variability is a big player here
but it doesn't exclude the possibility
because these climate models may be
missing natural variability as well
that's one of the challenges
to identify the role of natural
variability here a similar plot where
we're looking at a much shorter period
though which is always dangerous the
2006 to 2012 difference in sea ice
extent that was that period where we saw
this big decrease in observed CI six
time millions of square kilometers here
that's the observations now here how
many climate models over that same
period 2006 to 2012 we're able to
reproduce a trend and decrease as large
as that we observed so there actually
are a few that do but obviously the vast
majority not showing such a large
decrease this points to the idea that it
appears that the climate models are
maybe under sensitive to to the rate of
sea ice loss in the Arctic although
again we can't totally exclude the role
of natural variability and some of that
decrease so based on some of those
approaches we try to ask the question of
when we could go down to an ice-free
state which we defined is 1.7 million
square kilometers of sea ice in
late-september and the motivation was
basically there's a sort of huge spread
and assessments of when that when that
target could be reached as recently as
the last IPCC report they basically
suggests it was unlikely to happen
before 2100 or so and they've been a few
scientists who've said it could be as
early as 2015 so again I have much time
to go into this research but basically
we use two approaches i'll just talk
quickly about one we looked at those 35
or so seem up five models and looked at
how well they did it two metrics their
climate ology of sep tember sea ice over
that last 30 year period and their trend
in sea ice over that last 30 year period
and we kept those models that fell
within twenty percent of the
observations for both of those metrics
so here you have the observed average
September sea ice extent for 1979 to
2010 and then each of these GCMs and so
we basically would retain any GCM that
was in twenty percent of the
observations we take that group and the
union of that group and the group that
had a sea ice extent within twenty
percent a sea ice extent trend within
% of the observations and you end up
with eight retaining eight GCMs and
shown here is the average of the eight
GCMs that we retain for sea ice extent
and for sea ice trend it was really very
simple approach when we look at those
eight GCMs and then just sort of track
them and then the red line is going to
be the average of the eight at what
point do you reach that threshold that
we that we identified under our CP 8.5
you hit it in mid-2015 and interestingly
under our CP 4.5 which you know a lot of
people would argue is is a road maybe to
roseus scenario you actually in some of
the models never really do bottom out
actually can sort of find a stable state
at roughly that level so again these
climate models seem to be under
estimating the rate of sea ice loss I
think that caused us to need to be very
skeptical about it but still valuable I
think to look at the model so those
model-based approach alone suggests the
mid-20 50s my personal opinion is that
it's likely to be a lot sooner than that
but that really is just an opinion okay
and then just a couple more minutes here
to talk about some of the mid-latitude
research that we've we've led starting
with our paper and penis and in 2012 so
there was a sort of pattern of like
three or four winters in a row between
2007 and 2010 where there just seemed to
be a lot of areas that had heavy
snowfall throughout the northern
hemisphere that got a lot of attention
seeker at all reported a link to
negative to the North Atlantic
Oscillation possibly being having
explanatory power for the US and
northwest Europe also been some papers
linking positive phase of and so to
snowy winters when you just take a very
simple approach and just look we were
sort of motivated to look at those first
four winters so you see snow area across
the northern hemisphere north of 35 for
each of those four years if you
correlate again red being the the snow
extent for winter 2007 2008 2009 2010
there isn't a consistent relationship
with the a
positive aaon nal it's just treat is the
same here the the blue and the green and
some years positively correlated some
years negatively correlated same thing
for and so some years- some years
positive is act just a couple of years
but it was the motivation to sort of
look further at this whereas when we
looked at the at the sea-ice area for
September through November consistent
negative correlation although small in
one case for those four years so what
would a possible mechanism be to link
loss of sea ice in the Arctic to snowy
winters and cold air outbreaks and the
mid-latitudes so the basic idea proposed
in this mechanism is that when you lose
sea ice in late summer and early fall
you can get profound temperature
anomalies in the past now that's time of
year when the Sun disappears if you
essentially had almost a continental
surface with extensive sea ice
temperatures would drop really quickly
when you have open water in late summer
you're having additional solar radiation
especially in July and August still
getting in and warming things and then
you're going to have the sort of
persistence of that warmth it's going to
take time for the area to cool off again
as long as it takes essentially for
things to refreeze and some areas
temperatures are going to stay close to
even freezing as you get into say
October or self so you have very large
positive temperature anomalies what does
that mean when you have that warm air
when you have that potential for
moisture flux with an ice-free ocean
that brings surface a flux of heat and
moisture into the atmosphere and later
autumn maybe into early winter and what
we propose is that that could affect the
winter atmospheric circulation just to
quickly make the point that in 2007 we
had there was a big sea ice anomaly
there lots of additional solar radiation
came in and anomalous temperatures of as
much as seven degrees fahrenheit above
normal in 2007 okay so when we regret is
totally observations at this point when
we regressed the detrended autumn Arctic
sea ice record 19 September through
November over that 31 year period the
sea level pressure anomalies this is the
pattern we got some ways it looks like
the negative
l but not really you see that it's got a
less zonal structure so again just to
sort of point so the idea here is when
you have negative sea ice anomaly you
have higher pressure anomalously high
pressures over these areas and obviously
low pressures there so in some ways like
the negative AO but not quite that's the
sort of typical negative al phases you
can see more a more zonal look and
actually their time series correlation
is also fairly low between that
detrended autumn cic area in the winter
ale so something else going on here it's
not it's not the same as the AL so then
we're aggressed this again this fall
Arctic sea ice area anomaly on snow
cover december through februari with
units here of a million square
kilometers smaller actually than some of
the anomalies that were observed in sea
ice extent for 2007 and certainly 2012
and a tendency for something like
there's going to over about 30 years of
observed data tendency for something
like fifteen percent more snow in these
areas you see in red when you have that
low ha sea ice extent so we know clearly
natural variability is large in these
regions but you know you can see the
regression there and then what happens
if we look at the incidence of extreme
cold events also a somewhat similar
pattern when you have that luck is
regression again when you have that low
sea ice extent a tendency for these cold
air outbreaks as much as a fifty percent
increase in the frequency of these cold
air outbreaks especially over sort of
eastern parts of the contents but over a
much broader area as well so then we
went to climate models and did an
experiment we're using cam 3.1 two
different approaches one of control
basically using a sort of climatologist
easily varying of sea ice extent in the
Arctic and then a perturbation where we
took out sort of characteristic ice loss
in autumn and winter along the lines of
what we've observed in some recent years
and when we DIF those patterns these are
these are the actual anomalies in the
sea ice that we used in autumn and
winter
for the prescribed experiments and if
you look at what the models suggest a
pattern somewhat similar to the
observations when you have that lower
lower sea ice in the Arctic in the
models you do see that overall feature
of an anomalous high might actually look
more like VA 0 though someone like the
observed al and to some extent you see
as well in the temperature record may be
a tendency for forward somewhat of this
cold air outbreaks making their way and
although it doesn't look that much like
the observations but certainly it's some
so it's not a zonal structure and if we
compare the the observations for the
regression with the snow cover that I
showed earlier you can make the case
that there's some similarities in this
modeled pattern and I wouldn't go too
far with it we can't really expect the
models to get this right but I think
it's the first order you can make the
case that in the model experiments with
this one model some of the overall
features were reproduced low sea ice
cover being consistent with anomalously
high snowfall over parts of the
mid-latitudes especially sort of eastern
part of continents so I think that I'd
better wrap up there so we have some
time for questions I apologize for going
a little long probably quite a bit long
something that we're in the process of
writing up now what happens if we focus
on just the last six years when we've
been this you know very strong negative
sea ice anomaly and compare that period
so not a regression over the full 30
years but a differencing of these recent
six years that had a lot less sea ice is
that sort of a state change and we
haven't had a chance to compare this to
the natural variability yet but
certainly a tendency for anomalous highs
over the last six years in November and
eat anonymously easterly flow here that
paper and oceanography that i mentioned
noted that this is the type of flow that
can sort of help you get a sandy type
event but again one storm you can't go
too far with that but it is interesting
to to see this based on just six years
of observed data so i think i'll close
there apologize for running low
you